Holly she busts and I have a pool in the
mall too near here
just a dig at the more velocity Fillmore
be done my ball rock we don't lock
company head down come on another one -
I shall jump off invested to the film in
occupied East Jerusalem next to Israel's
wall checkpoints and settlements
Palestinians are getting high a few
years ago synthetic cannabis known by a
variety of names including mr. nice guy
appeared on the street it's cheaper more
addictive and can be more dangerous than
traditional drugs
as-siddiq attire is one of the main
rehabilitation centers treating drug
addicts in East Jerusalem I sat in on a
group therapy session with the young men
who are trying to get clean
[Music]
and again chefs who you know it's not a
secret that drugs are being sold and
used in East Jerusalem ask around and
ordinary people will tell you exactly
where in their neighborhoods it's
happening and in some cases it's right
in front of the Israeli authorities amok
to see is one of the main organizations
fighting drug use in East Jerusalem I
joined one of its field workers on a
trip to the shelf at refugee camp where
they often focus their prevention
efforts so far refugee camp is the most
overcrowded area of occupied East
Jerusalem and it's where you also find a
lot of drug use a Palestinian
supercilious taniyama can be fairly
messy and let dealers in McCann and a
husband's overrun Meribah so early be
stamina Bahadur - he had a law that when
the mother could young bitchy woman to
identify when after Nativity huh the
kids were right next Israel's checkpoint
and in plain sight for all to see stood
a group of addicts we wanted to
interview them but they demanded payment
in return nearby a steady stream of kids
passed through zeroth wall on their way
home from school
[Music]
well of the work when asked about mother
McCool Alana Claremont McKenna yeah
Ramona
yeah no VR food no Helen fellas know who
Nucky yes come on hero do women whore
the noodle humming hold each terminal
Yara for the math when I came on
Israel's anti-drug Authority is the main
body that focuses on fighting drugs here
to find out what they're doing about
synthetic cannabis I spoke with the
director of its treatment and
rehabilitation program dr. Hine Mel he
used to have huge cocaine reveling in
the last year's the problem is of the
synthetic drugs I can tell you that
among the young people that arrive to
detoxification units in 25 years old 60
percent arrived because of a synthetic
cannabinoids is the synthetic drugs are
arriving most of the time for me the Far
East it arrived to Israel and then they
mixed it with acetone and what happens
is they have some kind of solution that
they powered it on on leaves some kind
of list it can be also cannabis but it
not love it can be lived at the legal do
you think the the political situation in
East Jerusalem the occupation is having
an effect of course if you are under a
some kind of occupation you feel the
world and you are in a in a you are
using no God that sentiment was echoed
by a group of young Palestinian users
who at one point had all been arrested
by Israel for political activities in
East Jerusalem
Palacio de Mendoza - La Table on gossip
Polly Polly I miss eating raw fish shit
Sally that granted invisible until Yahoo
the bunratty Rahim love not destructive
shock in dr. Sturman and when effect
cervical